now to present the cinematography award
we have two of Hollywood's most
enthusiastic camera fiends and one of
its nicest couples Dick Powell and his
wife June Allyson
Oh Jim I didn't go overboard did I about
your enthusiasm for amateur photography
oh no I should say not by Richards got
at least 35 cameras the boy is really
gone it's odd that I am I've got one
camera use just to take pictures of the
other 34 but cameras are probably a lot
of fun as a hobby but it's a lot tougher
when you're a pro and cinematography
calls for a man well-equipped with skill
stamina and diplomacy lots of diplomacy
phone for instance I started the picture
last week with a cameraman I hadn't seen
in about 10 years after the first day's
work we went to see the rushes I didn't
like the way I looked so I turned to the
cameraman and scream I can't understand
it I never look like that
cameraman very politely answered
terribly sorry mr. power but you see I'm
ten years older well June on this high
note of diplomacy the nominations if you
please those nominated for achievement
in cinematography black and white
production our battleground
metro-goldwyn-mayer Halsey BOGO champion
screenplays corporation United Artists
Frank planner
come to the stable 20th Century Fox
Joseph's flesh he'll the Aris paramount
Leo told her prints of Fox's 20th
Century Fox Leone sham Roy mr. Horford
the envelope me the winner is Paul she
Vogel for battleground
here mr. policy
wonderful picture battleground and by
the way this is the first nomination for
mister volgas rules
was had he's accepting his Oscar for
these black-and-white cinematography
award for battleground those nominated
for the best achievement and
cinematography of a color production are
the batteries a Broadway
metro-goldwyn-mayer
Harris straddling Jolson sings again
Sidney Buckman production Columbia
William Snyder little women
metro-goldwyn-mayer Robert Frank and
Charles Sean bomb Sam 20th Century Fox
Charles G Clark she wore a yellow ribbon
Argosy Pictures corporation RKO radio
wet and Hutch the envelope please
the winner went and hutch where she wore
you have to choose from five
who the winner is what he's done women
Hotch the ward 1948 color cinematography
guillain-barré also photographer melody
time tap roots and three god
Thank You dick in German congratulations
when talk